Mark Zuckerberg was once on his way to becoming
the richest person in the world.
In September 2021, his net worth reached $142
billion, making him the third richest person
on Earth.
This man gave birth to the social media industry.
Yet today, the Facebook founder has seen his
net worth slashed by more than $100 billion…moving
him down to 28th place on the Bloomberg Billionaires
Index.
Zuckerberg’s fall reflects that of his company.
At one point, Meta was valued at $1 trillion.
Today, Facebook's parent company has lost
three-quarters of its value.
Its market value is now lower than that of
Home Depot.
On November 9, Meta announced it laid 11,000
people or 13% of its workforce.
That’s nearly triple the number of employees
Elon Musk let go from Twitter the week before.
In a message posted to his company’s website,
Zuckerberg wrote:
“I know this is tough for everyone, and
I’m especially sorry to those impacted.”
Meta has burned billions - spending so furiously
on its virtual world that predictions are
it could eventually cost more than the entire
Apollo moon program…which was more than
$250 billion adjusted for inflation.
We believe the metaverse will be the successor
to the mobile internet.
We believe in this vision so deeply that we
renamed our whole company after it.
Last year, in October 2021, Facebook the company
officially changed its name to Meta to reflect
a new focus.
The metaverse is a vision of the future where
people share virtual worlds through virtual
reality or augmented reality headsets.
Quest Pro is the first in a new line of advanced
headsets.
In the same way that everyone has a smartphone
today, Zuckerberg is betting they’ll have
a headset tomorrow.
He’s been intentionally pivoting away from
Facebook.
Facebook’s own research shows it's struggling
to keep young people interested.
Facebook’s number of daily active users
dropped at the end of 2021 for the first time.
And TikTok has been taking away eyeballs from
Meta’s Instagram while WhatsApp doesn’t
run ads.
It was already a painful year for Meta BEFORE
announcing the large-scale layoffs in November.
Meta dropped $232 billion in value in one
day in February.
Zuckerberg blamed it partly on Apple’s privacy
changes which gave iPhone owners the choice
of whether they’d allow apps like Facebook
to monitor their online activity.
If people opt out, Facebook receives less
user data, which makes targeting ads more
difficult, costing the company ad revenue.
But what’s been really dragging down Meta’s
profit is the ridiculous spending on the metaverse.
Spending on the metaverse is absolutely BONKERS.
Hey
Meta spent $10 billion on the metaverse in
2021 alone.
That’s 10 times what it paid to buy Instagram.
$10 billion is just a number I had trouble
processing.
I feel sick to my stomach thinking about that
much money being spent.”
John Carmack is an adviser to Meta and the
former chief technology officer at Oculus,
the VR company Facebook acquired.
His comments put him at odds with Zuckerberg,
who has put all his eggs in one metaverse
basket.
Zuckerberg is committed to a division of Meta
called Reality Labs - which makes VR and AR
headsets and software.
Reality Labs reportedly has 17,000 employees
- that’s four times the size of Twitter’s
entire workforce.
Like other tech companies, Meta went on a
hiring spree during the pandemic as everyone
was locked away at home on their computer.
But now, Zuckerberg admits Meta grew too quickly;
the global economy has slowed, inflation has
soared, and investors are nervous about costs.
Facebook has weathered storms before - even
scandals related to privacy and misinformation
didn’t hurt its financial performance.
But this time…it’s different.
Although tech stocks have been in a slump,
Meta’s problems far outpace both the Nasdaq
and the S&P 500.
November’s job cuts are the most significant
since the company was founded in 2004.
A hiring freeze will be extended until March
2023.
Employees will lose some perks.
They already lost free laundry and dry cleaning
earlier in the year.
Zuckerberg is asking his employees and investors
to trust him.
And his plan for the metaverse.
In fact, he’s made himself the face of his
company’s push for the metaverse.
According to the New York Times, some meta
employees refer to metaverse projects as M.M.H.,
an acronym for “make Mark happy.”
But he wasn’t very happy after he posted
a selfie in Meta’s virtual reality social
network Horizon Worlds and the world laughed
at him for how ridiculous it looked.
People on Twitter were RUTHLESS, comparing
Horizon Worlds to something outdated from
decades ago.
In response to the mocking, Zuckerberg promised
the graphics would get a lot better and shared
an improved version three days later.
But even Meta’s employees are barely using
its own metaverse app!
In September, the vice president in charge
of Meta’s metaverse division, Vishal Shah,
wrote in an internal message board obtained
by The Verge: “The simple truth is, if we
don’t love it, how can we expect our users
to love it?”
He said managers would start tracking employees'
use of Horizon Worlds.
Nearly all of Zuckerberg’s wealth is tied
up in Meta stock.
So he’s betting his entire fortune on the
success of his vision for the future.
During Meta’s earnings call in October,
Zuckerberg defiantly said:
“I get that a lot of people might disagree
with this investment.
I think people are going to look back on decades
from now and talk about the importance of
the work that was done here.”
But for now, as one headline proclaims, its
metaverse dream feels as far away as ever.
It remains to be seen whether the metaverse
will transform our lives.
There is another company transforming the
shaving industry.
Henson Shaving makes one of the very best
razors in the world.
Henson knows a thing or two about making a
great product because their razors are manufactured
out of the same machine shop in Canada that
built products for the International Space
Station!
So their razors are made to aerospace standards.
The blade is only minimally exposed; the amount
that the blade extends past the shave plane
is less than the thickness of a strand of
human hair which allows Henson to limit the
blade from flexing, to deliver that smooth
and safe shave.
Henson has sponsored quite a few of my videos,
and my viewers really love their products.
Their razors are completely plastic-free,
and so are their blades.
The blades only cost about ten cents so once
you own a Henson razor, it’s only about
$3 to $5 a year to shave depending on how
often you shave.
Their safety razor lasts years if not decades.
So over time, the cost of owning a Henson
is much less than a cartridge razor.
Plus, it’s environmentally friendly.
Henson ships all around the world, and they're
offering you a special deal.
If you use my discount code: NEWSTHINK, you’ll
get a pack of 100 blades for FREE.
Be sure to add the 100-pack to your shopping
cart first…BEFORE entering my code.
My custom link is in the description.
And by the way, their razors also make for
a great gift!
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.